so I'm very honored to be here to
present I'm actually doing two separate
categories here and not only am i doing
animation but there's another category
called alternative filmmaking and I and
I hadn't been familiar with that
category and I wondered if it meant that
you know it involve different lifestyles
or that you had music by REM in it or
something I wasn't sure but but actually
alternative films often challenged the
language of film make they make personal
expression and aesthetic exploration
their primary concerns now in the other
categories you know there have been the
gold silver and bronze award winners
well in this category the the actually
there is only and the winner should be
more relaxed because there was only one
nominee in this category i find it
somewhat ironic in the category of
alternative filmmaking there's no
alternatives but this one person but but
he a wonderful filmmaker we are going to
he did a film his name is tall s shamir
and don't come up yet at all because
we're going to show your film actually
his entry is entitled the Vermeer's as
humbly as possible i would like to thank
the academy for recognizing the Volm use
it is it is an amazing recognition
information for an alternative strange
feeling like this I would also like to
thank rich miller and his team for this
amazing week this has been overwhelming
and and I salute all the other
filmmakers who are amazing filmmakers
and I'd love to work with you on
anything and the Vermeer's visions and
experience of young Vermeer's paintings
from the view of the iphone generation
it tries to combine and merge the
content of the art film in this case
Vermeer's paintings with the structure
of the film trailer so it's basically a
a trailer for Vermeer's paintings the
film tries to be loyal to the source and
to his paintings but to to the
technological evolution this film could
not have happened without the amazing
support of the new school faculty in
particular my two main tools danza
berries and waffle power it could also
not have happened without its tiny crew
but that gave all its hub maybe still
marcos and my two wonderful actors jose
episode Lena's and Lisa Madison and I
must share this award with my mother for
being an excellent producer and a
brilliant brilliant our director for
this film thank you so much for this
great honor thank you for giving this
thank you